hi there my name is fairy pie let's eat
some candy today I've collected five of
the most disgusting candy I could
possibly find why because I love that
[ __ ]
you Bruce won't believe what some of
these candies are I could not believe
them when I sell them hopefully I won't
throw up
I'm really bad at eating disgusting
things I think you've noticed that
already
Swedish boy it's disgusting candy what I
like and a little bit of this to kick
off last candy number one curry flavored
Cali mints Tori flavor mints okay let's
try these out maybe they won't taste
like a complete [ __ ] it's really bad
idea and take a shot before it's [ __ ] oh
my god they're brown hey you want some
in they look like [ __ ] true story
I stuck one of these in my nose when I
was a kid and my mom had to take a straw
to blow it out thanks mom all right here
we go
[Music]
they're honestly not that bad
I could totally eat these as candies
they do taste like curry I wouldn't
really call it meant but they're not
disgusting gotta rinse that [ __ ] cainy
number two garlic sweet flavor I think
these are used to prank people well I'm
about to prank myself baby why am I
talking like this I don't know man just
can't help it
yeah how old is this oh this is what my
brothers Oh
[Music]
good-o
once you get past the gagging reflexes
it's pretty good on this thing idea my
way all right I need some different
flavor I need some different consistency
what's this oh let me show you
it says edible anus Wow
yes hey son here you go some eatable
anus for you boy thanks dude so it's
basically chocolate shaped like an anus
like a pooper why is it so out of focus
come on man look at this anus it's about
to be in my mouth
it's almost like I've done this before
it does not taste like anus trust me I
would know kind of disappointed to be
honest the fourth item is bubblegum
hairballs hairballs bubblegum [ __ ] you
let's try these hair balls out Oh for
[ __ ] sake disgust okay okay I don't
know what this flavor is but here we go
[Music]
it's not a hairball well at least we
gotta rinse that [ __ ] bros we're at the
final item the final candy of this video
what are you what do you think so far I
agree I should kill myself saving the
best for last we got fish sweets so fish
flavored candy I'm not excited for this
[ __ ] it's for you bro
oh it's all soft
[Music]
that was fun I joy all right press if
you enjoyed this episode I'm gonna give
away give it I'll give it a gap yeah but
I get old give it and you better go to
like subscribe to come over today brush
I will see you in the next one as always
it's mommy
I want that ass [ __ ] cheese nice
alright stay awesome press but it's not
just any candy it's poop candy so there
it's called pooping Kent candy dispenser